à l'instar d'autres pays victimes des
sanctions américaines cuba se voit
freiné dans son combat contre la
pandémie de covin 19
il est effectivement très compliqué pour
la vanne de commande et du matériel
médical venant de l'étranger
dernier exemple en date des commandes de
respirateurs suisse réalisée par les
autorités cubaines aurait été refusée
la raison ces entreprises ne veulent pas
courir le risque de possibles sanctions
américaines
des blocages inacceptables pour huit ong
locales qui ont cosigné un communiqué
parmi elles il ya notamment en média
cuba suisse une association oeuvrant
pour la mise en place de projets
médicaux commun entre les deux pays
avec sept autres organisations de la
société civile suisse mehdi cuba suisse
condamne fermement les mesures prises
récemment par le gouvernement des états
unis contre cuba qui sont contraires au
droit international et en cette période
de pandémie simplement criminel et dont
les effets directs s'étendent jusqu'en
suisse
au delà de la question des respirateurs
le blocus américain s'impose aussi aux
banques helvétiques
plusieurs établissements bancaires du
pays auraient ainsi bloquer des
transferts de dons entre leurs clients
des dons sens et l'a aussi aidé la
havane en termes de tests et de matériel
de protection
idem lorsqu'au début du mois d'avril un
avion rempli de matériel médical envoyé
par la chine n'a jamais pu atterrir à
cuba le transporteur américain avait
finalement décliné la aussi par peur des
sanctions
l'embargo des états unis sur cuba a été
renforcée ces derniers mois sous
l'impulsion de donald trump
des poursuites ont notamment été lancés
contre des entreprises ayant réalisé des
affaires sur le sol cubain une politique
déjà contesté en temps normal et qui est
devenu encore plus problématique en
pleine pandémie
les appels à la levée de ces sanctions
se multiplient notamment de la part de
michelle bachelet haut commissaire des
nations unies aux droits comme tant pour
des raisons de santé publique mondiale
que pour appuyer les droits et la vie de
millions de personnes dans ces pays les
sanctions sectorielle doivent être
assouplies ou suspendus dans ce contexte
de pandémie mondiale entraver les
efforts médicaux dans un pays accroît
les risques pour nous tous la situation
autour de cet embargo que
les etats unis imposent reste du monde a
de quoi interroger au moment où cuba on
voit des équipes médicales y compris sur
le territoire français ce samedi ce sont
216 médecins cubains qui ont été
dépêchés en afrique du sud
au total depuis le début de la pandémie
1200 professionnels de santé ont quitté
l'île des caraïbes pour venir en aide à
d'autres pays
un geste d'autant plus honorable que la
réciproque est donc pas toujours
possible